[Music]
a few weeks back we showed you how
discarded goldfish are taking over a
minnesota lake
some of them have grown to the size of a
football and are actually damaging the
lake's ecosystem
while those fish aren't harmful to
humans some other abandoned pets
might be charlie demar visited a refuge
for some pretty large reptiles
godzilla is 12 feet long and too heavy
for the scale at the prichlow alligator
sanctuary
godzilla come up he's the biggest of the
200 or so animals here
each with its own story and too often a
troubled past
the second alligator his name is quasi
and actually the one right next to it is
linus those two came together
and they were locked in a closet and
left her dead
the roadside refuge has been in lena
kelly's family for decades
did i tell you how many sounds
alligators make her dad david still
leads tours
after about a year and a half his
backbone straightened right up
unfortunately people purchase them and
then don't want to keep them for their
lifetime
we have quite a few that came from drug
houses or drug raids
the problem crosses the country this
alligator was pulled from a home in new
hampshire
officers on a drug raid in california
came across
one in a rickety tank full of rancid
water
two five-foot alligators were recently
seized from a kentucky man
and in 2019 chance the snapper made
headlines
after he was dumped in the pond of a
chicago park
many of our animals because they've all
been raised by people they can't go to
the wild so there is no option for them
so in some cases these alligators would
have nowhere else to go correct yeah
so they end up here a most unexpected
oasis
nestled in the farm fields near battle
creek michigan
and with so many gators turning up where
they don't belong
lena and the staff decided to train
animal control professionals
sal palumbo owns an animal removal
business in michigan
ready for a trip he's so sure he'll get
a call
soon he came here in april to learn the
right way to wrangle the reptiles
even with training the dangers are high
an alligator is an apex predator
he has capability that a lot of people
certainly would never even imagine
and with the training comes a new found
respect
for cbs this morning saturday charlie
demar athens michigan
my favorite part is the names
chance godzilla snapper you ever
wrestled an alligator before
i have never wrassled an alligator
never they are not pets and don't want
to